FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
Today it's my absolute
pleasure to welcome
Mars Hallman, the winner
of the 2015 GLSEN Respect
Award for the Student
Advocate of the Year.
And Stephanie
Frosch, who you might
know as ElloSteph from YouTube.
Thanks both for being here.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Thank
you for having us.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to start off by
talking about gender pronouns,
because that's what one does.
I think it's an important thing,
because I think it's something
that maybe the public doesn't
always wrap their head around
easily, but it's important
to the people who
want to be identified
maybe not as "he,"
"she," or anything in between.
So Mars, I'm going to
let you take this one.
Can you explain
to us a little bit
about how you prefer
to be referred to?
And the reasoning for that?
MARS HALLMAN: All right.
I use the pronouns
"they," "them," and
"theirs," because they
don't have the gender
connotation of "he," "him,"
"his," or "she," "her," "hers."
And you use it in the same way
you would if you were talking
in the third person plural.
It's very simple.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And the
reasoning for that is?
MARS HALLMAN: They're
important to me.
I'm non-binary.
And they reaffirm my gender
identity when people use them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And just can
you explain what "non-binary"
is for our viewers out there.
MARS HALLMAN: I'm not a
boy, and I'm not a girl,
and I'm not anything in between.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
So Mars, you are the Student
Advocate of the Year.
Can you talk about what some
of the process of becoming
an advocate for the LGBTQ,
everyone in-between, community
was like for you?
MARS HALLMAN: Well, my process
was being the Q in LGBTQ.
Growing up as the Q, you see a
lot of bullying and inequality
and harassment, and you see
that happening to your friends
and to yourself.
And you grow up and you
become strong from that,
and you-- I grew up having the
privilege of having parents who
support me and having
a safe place at home
knowing my friends
don't have that.
I know that school
and the workplace
are the places that are
going to be safe for them.
So I know that I have to make
those places safe for them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And you led
an effort at your school,
in particular, to
kind of make sure
that there were
bathrooms that were
appropriate for
anybody who didn't
want to identify as either one.
Can you talk about some
of the other things
that you kind of took
care of along the way that
helped create this safe space?
MARS HALLMAN: Well, I started
the Gay-Straight Alliance
at my school, the first
one in the region.
Woo.
[APPLAUSE]
And that itself was a struggle.
Getting support from local
parents wasn't going to happen,
so we got a sponsor.
I spoke myself to the principal.
I got the resources from GLSEN
and from the Gay-Straight
Alliance Network and
proposed the club.
And it was deferred to a
school board meeting decision,
which was then deferred.
And they announced
through the paper
that it was going to be allowed.
So the Gay-Straight
Alliance started.
We had our first
meetings recently.
Actually, at the
start of Ally Week.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Congratulations.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Wow.
MARS HALLMAN: So so far we've
the worked on educating people
on gender pronouns,
gender identities,
and done some just fun
activities making sure everyone
knows that they're welcome at
school no matter who they are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
Steph, you have a larger
kind of platform to use.
You are a YouTube sensation.
STEPHANIE FROSCH:
I do the YouTube.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
You do the YouTube.
Could you talk to us
about-- you definitely bring
kind of a positive air
and, like, an air of humor
to these issues that
I think we need.
You know, I think if
you get too caught
in the they're serious
issues, they're
kind of sometimes
upsetting issues,
but you bring this very,
like, hey, it's OK.
It's fine.
It's fun.
Can you talk about kind of
the process of developing
your voice online?
STEPHANIE FROSCH:
Well, I started when
I was in high school on Tumblr.
And the reason why my
Tumblr sort of grew
was because at the
time it was very rare
finding a feminine lesbian
on the internet at my age.
I mean, this is 2011,
but at the same time,
it was like finding
a shiny Pokemon.
So that's how I grew
my audience on Tumblr.
And from there, I
would just write.
I was very big into
writing, but eventually I
had a fan say, I really
love what you write,
but I hate reading.
Could you make a video?
And I was like, I have
all this free time.
Why not?
So not having a life
actually paid off.
And it just kind
of grew from there.
And I realized that I started
getting more serious questions
in regards to being
kicked out of your home
to things like wanting
to commit suicide.
And from there I wanted to be
more certified to answer those
questions, because I
felt like I wasn't.
So I got my certification
in suicide prevention.
And I was on the board
for LGBTQ+ services
at my university.
And from there I
was like, how can I
include entertainment
and these issues
that I'm so passionate about?
So a way that I see it is
like dipping a broccoli
in chocolate.
So one of my most
successful videos,
which is about
gender recognition
and sexuality recognition, is
called "Never Have I Ever,"
which, you know, that
popular game "never, ever
have I done this."
So it starts out
fun and cheerful,
and then it gets into
more serious issues
with the statistics.
So I'm like, if
I can get someone
to watch something and be
intrigued by it while still
learning and keeping
it at a lighter note,
then I feel like you're
more likely to take that in
and more likely to be accepting.
And it's how we learn.
It's how we process.
But always in school,
you want to get an A
because the teacher
then congratulates you
not because the
teacher puts you down
for getting the answer wrong.
So I feel like that's
how society is.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's very
carrot, not the stick.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You
made an amazing point
where we do live in this kind
of wonderful era where maybe,
apparently even
four years ago, it's
tough to find someone
who maybe identifies
in the same way you do.
You know, we're all individuals,
we're all different,
but if you grew up in
a small town, maybe,
you don't necessarily
have those resources.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
But, Mars, for you
was the internet kind of playing
a role in your support system
and kind of getting your
efforts off the ground?
MARS HALLMAN: Yes.
The internet is
where I first learned
about queer and
transgender issues
through just various support
groups and just databases.
Just learning statistics.
I contacted the Gay-Straight
Alliance Network
through the internet.
A lot of Google searching.
And that's how I got in contact
with Anna Davis and Chris
Hampton of the
ACLU, and that was
where we got a lot of the
support for getting the GSA.
And just for learning
that it's OK to be me.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Steph,
I think that's one
of the things you kind of
touch on in most of your videos
is like, it's OK to be you.
It's OK to be whatever.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Yeah, because
oftentimes in small towns
you don't have that
reassurance that it's OK.
And the internet is an
amazing outreach for that.
I mean, I went to a
religious private school
from kindergarten
to senior year,
or as I like to call
it "Jew school."
And it was great,
but at the same time,
I was the only a LGBTQ+
identified person.
So I had no resources.
I had no one to go to.
But by simply typing
something into the internet,
I had a community.
I had the support.
I had the outreach.
And I feel like that's so
important for Millennials
and the new generations
today is we're so
connected now that no one
has to be alone anymore.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Is that--
what's one thing you really
hope that your audience
takes away from your videos?
Is it that is that
you're not alone?
Is it--
STEPHANIE FROSCH:
It's definitely
that they're not alone
and definitely how
not everything in society
needs to be a taboo subject.
I mean, even back in the day,
my first college roommate
was gender non-binary, and
they weren't comfortable even
bringing it up in
conversation because people
weren't talking about it.
And I feel like the
more we talk about it
and say it's OK to talk about
it, the less of a "big deal"
it's going to be.
It's going to be, oh,
these are your pronouns?
Yeah?
Those are your pronouns.
Versus what is this?
And then making
a big deal of it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Mars,
you said something
earlier that I enjoyed.
And you said, like,
Nashville isn't a bad place.
And could you talk
a little bit more
about that in terms of,
like, finding acceptance
in the real world space
versus the internet?
MARS HALLMAN: Well, I grew up
in a few different environments.
I had a kind of a city
upbringing and a country
upbringing.
And then we moved to Nashville
a few years ago on purpose.
We didn't think, oh, no.
We've ended up in the
middle of nowhere.
What will we do?
There's a really
great community there
with some very vocal people
who would oppose change.
But also, when I started the GSA
and when I started campaigning
for equality in my school,
lots of adult allies,
either from Nashville or who
still lived there or had moved
away, came to me and
my mother with messages
of support or thanks.
Some of them would send monetary
contributions to the GSA,
some of them would send their
words and their stories.
So it's a good town
with good people.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
It's good to know.
It's good to know that there's
support when you asked for it.
I'd love to know-- this
is not-- unfortunately
the internet is a
very supportive place,
but the internet
can also be somewhat
of a disrespectful place.
And I think you both
probably deal very well
with those types
of comments and are
able to kind of brush them off.
And what's some
advice you'd give
to people who are
kind of dealing
with the trolls of the internet?
STEPHANIE FROSCH:
I mean, the way
I see it, in life in general
you can't please everyone,
regardless if it's on
or off the internet.
There's always going to be
someone with a different view
than yours.
And although I see it as we
don't have the same views,
I feel like we should
still respect it.
And some people
don't respect it.
So whenever I see a troll
or someone like that,
I feel more sorry
for them because I'm
like, if you're that
insecure, that's
why you're fixating
on my life and what
I'm doing because I
don't go out of my way
to bring someone down.
The only time that
you bring someone down
is when you are
yourself falling,
which is a struggle that I
feel that they deal with.
So instead I just ignore them.
I am fortunate where I don't
have a lot of "haters."
I don't know if that's
a good or a bad thing,
because it can bring discussion.
It can bring awareness.
And the ones that I
have had, it's just been
very petty things like, wow.
You're so gay.
And I'm like, yeah.
I am.
Thank you for that observation.
But just simply, like, viewing
it as not taking it personally,
because oftentimes
it's their issue.
And even in person,
those are the things
that got to me the
most growing up
when I was called
slurs in high school
when I was first out
about my orientation.
My mom used to always
tell me that in even four
years from now, four days from
now, it's not going to matter.
And it's true.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Very much so.
Yeah.
And you bring up your mom.
Mars, your mother's
here with us today.
Are there things
that you would say
to kind of families in order
to-- what advice would you
give to families
who maybe do have
children who they don't
necessarily immediately
understand?
Like, what resources would
you try and point them to?
Or what was the thing that
was also most helpful for you
in dealing with your family
and your coming outs?
MARS HALLMAN: Well,
one my parents
were very open to
just listening to me.
I would introduce a topic, and
whatever they could understand
for me, you know, my
mom took the initiative
and would look up GLSEN
or PFLAG resources.
Just making sure that
your child's safety,
and respecting your child's
safety, is number one always.
To make sure that
your questioning
them is for the benefit of
learning them as a person
and not for trying
to change them.
Make sure you're just
learning about them.
STEPHANIE FROSCH:
My biggest thing
is, especially-- my dad taught
me this, surprisingly enough.
My dad is very old school,
but also very accepting.
But the way that I
see it is I remember
one time I had my college
roommate coming home after they
first came out,
and I told my dad,
you know, they go
by these pronouns.
This is what you do.
And he's just nodding along.
And I asked him, are
you following this?
And he said, you know,
I don't understand it,
but that doesn't mean I'm
not going to respect it.
And that's the way I
feel like it should be.
You don't have to grasp
something and know everything
about it right away
to validate a person
and give them the respect
that they deserve.
And a big thing that
I've also noticed
is, especially from when I get
fan mail, a lot of the youth
say how their parents
don't accept them.
So that means they're
never going to accept them.
They don't have
a family anymore.
Which isn't true
either, and I feel
like that's important to really
recognize that coming out
is a process also for the
person hearing the news.
So my dad, when
I first told him,
it was very much of a we're not
going to bring this up ever.
And now my dad is
super supportive.
And it can change.
Your parents can change.
So I know so many
people are quick to say,
I don't have a family anymore.
It's done.
But give them time.
Parents are close to
perfect in our eyes,
but everyone has growing room.
And they can learn from
their children as well.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think that's
a wonderful kind of point
and I think the
whole, it gets better,
the kind of publicity
and awareness
that the recent
movements have had
have definitely been
helpful in that.
And so it's nice to hear
that there are resources
and there are outlets for people
who are willing to change.
And I think everyone has
the capacity to change.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What
is one of the moments
that you're most proud of
in your kind of activism
and careers?
The award tonight?
MARS HALLMAN: I'm
pretty proud of that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You should be.
MARS HALLMAN: My proudest moment
would be back in junior year
when it was the day I decided
that I was going to go through
with making sure we had a
Gay-Straight Alliance before I
graduated.
One of my best friends
isn't out at home,
isn't out to anyone,
everyone suspects,
was being sexually harassed on
the daily by upper classmen.
And it was because he
was perceived as queer.
And for the first
time I responded
to a situation levelheaded,
removed him, reported it.
And that day when I got home,
I wrote up our guidelines,
I recruited our sponsor,
and a week later we
had a club in motion.
Like, that's what I'm
proudest of is just response.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
STEPHANIE FROSCH:
That's incredible.
Sorry. [INAUDIBLE]
not from that.
Am I allowed to have,
like, an online one
and a non-online one?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: I feel
like it's Hannah Montana
with these two [INAUDIBLE].
My favorite in-person
accomplishment is when I was
on the board for LGBTQ+
services at my university.
I went to the University
of Central Florida,
and it's a student
body of 60,000.
And we have a huge
LGBTQ+ population,
but we had social clubs but
we need more than just social
sometimes.
So we were
literally-- our office
was a closet in the student
union within someone else's
office.
And it was a great having
all six of us in this closet,
but-- oh, we were in the closet.
Look at that.
But we were really
trying to make
a safe space, which
we did accomplish,
called Pride Commons.
And we had several meetings with
the whole student government.
It was a real struggle
to get our needs met,
but eventually we got
an entire huge room
in the middle of our university
where there's resources.
We partnered up with
victim services.
We had an entire legal
team so if a student wanted
to change their name,
then all of that
would be taken care of, like,
free of charge for them.
And that's definitely
the biggest
in-person accomplishment.
And then online I feel like
it's a victory every day
when I get a message from
someone, again, saying hi.
Four years ago I thought
it would not get better.
I thought that my life was
over, but you told me this.
And now I'm doing this.
Now I'm at this school.
Now I have this partner.
Now I have this
relationship with my peers.
And just seeing a huge
growth in someone,
even if I never met
them face-to-face,
getting to really feel how their
life is significantly better
is-- there's no words for it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
You both very much
inspire others,
but I'd love to know
who inspires you.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Oh, gosh.
This is so hard.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Like a pop quiz.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Is it-- I
don't want to be stereotypical,
but I love Ellen.
And it's not just because
she rocks blazers,
as I hope to one day,
but it's because I
feel like her entire
energy is about positivity.
And that's what I want to do.
So even through
negative situations,
things can get better.
And I remember, especially
after my mom passed away
during my senior year of
high school, something
that I would have in
common with my mom
is she watched the "Ellen Show."
So what made me feel
better is seeing, like,
old "Ellen Shows"
and just seeing
how even though something
terrible can happen,
you don't have to
pretend it didn't happen.
You don't have to
pretend it's better.
But you can grow from it.
You can make something
positive afterwards.
And just remember that
every negative experience
isn't a wall that's blocked.
The road keeps going,
and you can change
the direction it goes in.
So Ellen is a very
big inspiration
for me along with a really
close friend of mine
named Raymond Braun.
He does a lot of the advocacy
and online marketing for, like,
the-- oh, my goodness.
I'm, like, blanking right now
and I was on this project.
AUDIENCE: Proud to
Play and Proud to Love.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Yes.
Thank you.
Proud to Play and Proud to Love.
He came up with all of that.
And he's just one of the
most humble individuals
I've ever met in my life.
And he is just so active
online and in person.
So he's another huge,
huge inspiration to me.
MARS HALLMAN: My biggest
inspirations so far
have been the entire
staff of the Queer
Youth Leading the South Camp,
which I went to last summer.
And it was a five-day long camp,
and Foster Noon and Mustafa
Sullivan really
helped guide me, like,
spiritually and personally.
And I've learned
a lot from them.
They're both activists
and advocates.
Mustafa does work in
New York and California
and travels back and
forth with youth.
And I realized from him
that I want to do that.
His life is the life I
want to contribute to.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
What is some of the best
advice someone has given you?
It could be about anything.
It doesn't have
to be about this.
Just in general.
STEPHANIE FROSCH:
I have a professor
that I'm very close with at
my university named Sybil St.
Claire, and with her
I did a lot of theater
for social change,
which became, like,
my biggest passion in college.
And something she told
me during my freshman
year, my first
class, was sometimes
you have to be comfortable
being uncomfortable,
because that's
where we most grow.
So even if we're in
a situation where
we don't like what's going on,
we don't like being vulnerable,
we sometimes have to
do it, because society
has engraved in us that
vulnerability is weakness.
But really it's allowing
yourself the strength to feel.
So if something
isn't going your way,
whether it's an event or
situation, you can grow in it.
MARS HALLMAN: Well, my
dad's a music teacher--
he's my music teacher.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Oh, awesome.
MARS HALLMAN: Yeah.
And when we're getting
ready for a big audition
or a competition,
he'll say, just
practice 15 minutes tonight.
And I'll say, but I'm supposed
to practice more than that.
And he'll say, practice
15 minutes tonight.
Practice 15 minutes.
And then the next day
I'll say, how long?
And he'll say, practice
15 minutes tonight.
And so I'll get ready for honor
band and I'll get stressed
and I'll say, I haven't
practiced enough.
And he'll say, have you
practiced 15 minutes every day?
And I'll say, yes.
And he says, you've
practiced enough.
You practiced every day.
So just kind of taking
everything chunks at a time.
You feel like you're not ready
for something, you have time.
Give yourself 15
minutes every day.
Get yourself ready.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
advice we all could use here.
What-- time metric doesn't
usually work for you guys,
you're so young-- but if
you could tell yourself
five years ago, you tell
yourself five years ago self
something, what would it be?
If you could go like "Back to
the Future" style and be like,
the Cubs are going
to lose this year.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Five years.
I was in high school.
I mean, besides telling myself,
you know, don't try and rock
the Shane from
"The L Word" look,
because you can't, I
guess the biggest advice--
[LAUGHTER]
We all know that look.
I guess the biggest thing is
that even though things seem
awful and even if
it's raining outside
and there doesn't seem to
be any light going through,
it doesn't mean the sun
isn't behind those clouds.
Things do get better.
They will get better.
I mean, if I was telling myself
five years ago that I would
have an online following
with hundreds of thousands
of incredible youth wanting
to make a difference,
I would have never believed it.
I mean, in high
school I literally
ate lunch in the bathroom
like in "Mean Girls."
And it didn't have
that happy ending.
So I didn't think that it
was going to get better.
I didn't think one person
would value my opinion,
let alone an entire community.
And I feel like it's
just important to take
every experience as
a growing opportunity
and realizing that even the
negatives isn't an ending.
A positive isn't an ending.
It can even get
better from there.
And just realizing it
can get so much better
if you apply your mind to it.
MARS HALLMAN: Well--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Practice.
MARS HALLMAN: I was about 11.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is why I
didn't want ask the question.
MARS HALLMAN: I would have told
myself to stop wearing Crocs.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Good advice.
Good advice.
MARS HALLMAN: And
that my parents
are going to love
me unconditionally
and I've got nothing
to be afraid of.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great advice.
MARS HALLMAN: Except
for those Crocs.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Except for the Crocs.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: The
international shoe
of giving up.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Last
question from me
is what's one simple thing
that you think people
can do to help be an Ally?
STEPHANIE FROSCH: I
feel like the biggest
thing to be an Ally is not to
be afraid to ask questions,
because I feel like the easiest
way to grow against something
is because we don't know.
It's a lot easier to say, I hate
this versus I don't know this.
Let me take the opportunity
to understand it.
So I feel like asking questions
and being honest about it
and coming at it
through a place of love
and wanting to learn
versus ignorance
is one of the main things.
Definitely passing the
mic to communities.
I mean, when that terrible event
with Leelah Alcorn happened,
I wanted to make
a video about it.
But I was like, I definitely
am too privileged to discuss
the transgender community.
So let me pass this
mic, and in my video,
I'm not even in the video
because it's not my story.
It belongs to this community.
So I feel like knowing
when to pass the mic
and knowing when
to ask questions
is the biggest thing you
can do to be an Ally.
MARS HALLMAN: Always affirm.
Don't question
someone's feelings
about being trans, being queer.
Know your intersections.
When someone comes
to you and tells you,
you're coming to me from
a place of privilege
and you're not understanding,
don't say, I do understand.
I do.
Because you don't.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: No, you don't.
MARS HALLMAN: You don't.
And that's OK.
You can only gain
that understanding
by listening when
someone tells you,
you're coming to
me with privilege.
Say, yes.
Yes, I am.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do we
have audience questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming
out and chatting with us
and to all the online audience,
chatting with them as well.
You have a ton of
people supporting you
who are older adults--
you are adults as well,
but, you know, people your
parents' age, our age.
And at times it may feel
that we're disconnected
from you and your experience.
You know, we're not
in school day-to-day.
You know, we're in
the workplace, which
is a little bit different.
And there are, you know,
different rules and structures
around each place.
But I would ask
for me personally
and for all of the adults
out there who do support you,
what can we do to help you more?
What can we do to sort
of bridge that connection
between your world and
our world where we may
be able to do more to help you?
And what does that look like?
And what could we do?
MARS HALLMAN: It
looks like listening.
It looks like open ears.
When a young person comes to
you with their experience,
you can't come back at
them with, your young.
It'll get better.
You're young.
Just wait a few years.
Because for some of us,
we can't wait any more.
We can't wait any more years.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: It's called
Twitter, and what-- no,
besides that.
I mean, my dad knows nothing
about the internet at all,
but the biggest thing is
that I notice especially
with my professors and
parents and parents of friends
is even if we're not going
to you but even saying,
I'm here if and when you want to
talk, that's the biggest thing.
The reason why I was so
comfortable coming out
to my mom is because even
when I was not ready,
was not going to talk,
she always let me know,
I'm here to listen.
So definitely keeping open
ears like Mars suggested.
And then, especially I know
at least from, like, my dad,
he always says, you
don't have it that bad.
When I was your age-- so I
feel like just not belittling
one's experience,
because weight is--
you know, what is
10 pounds to me
is going to be nothing to,
like, a heavyweight champion.
So everyone has a different
definition of weight.
And just being there.
Just being open, honest,
having those ears.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARS HALLMAN: Thank you.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You guys, first
off, thank you for being here.
And I'm totally blown
away by you two.
I've been sitting here, like,
on the edge of tears just blown
away by youth and your strength
in both how you show that.
Steph, your videos
are great, but I'm
going to address this to Mars
because there would be no way
that I could have summoned
up the courage to do anything
like what you've
done in high school.
And so I guess what
I'd like to know,
in creating that in
an environment that's
not some liberal West
Coast enclave-- I mean,
you are out there
doing it-- maybe give
one thing that surprised you
when you actually went through
with it in a positive way and
maybe any negative backlash
that you've had to overcome.
I guess I'm just really
interested that you've
done this.
I'm just sitting here-- you
are like this wise person
and really impressive.
MARS HALLMAN: Thank you.
I'm going to start
with the negative one,
because I don't want to
end with a negative one.
AUDIENCE: Feel free.
MARS HALLMAN: A
negative surprise.
All the faith backlash.
I think that any faith
should be a home,
and when you use what should be
a shield as a weapon to hurt,
that's what surprised me the
most and was really awful.
I know a lot of my friends came
to me and said, what do I do?
My parents are huge
supporters of this church
that's telling me you personally
are dragging us to hell.
What do I do?
And not having answers for them.
That was the worst surprise.
But good surprises.
All of the adult support
that I wasn't expecting
from not just South Georgia,
but all over Georgia, all
over the South, all over the US.
Anyone who's read
my story, people
who would just mention it
and say, hey, I'm from there.
I survived your school.
Or, hey, I can't send you money,
I'm going to send you a prayer.
I'm going to send
you these words.
And then being able to
pass on those messages
to the members of the
Gay-Straight Alliance
and having them see, that
person's, like, 40 years old
and they were gay in
Berry and they lived?
So that was the
best surprise was
when older people would
come back and reach out back
to me, back to my peers.
I really wasn't expecting that,
and it was really inspiring.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Thank you guys for being
here, and have fun tonight.
MARS HALLMAN: Thank you.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I think,
you know, growing up,
especially at this
time, there's a lot
of, like, online resources.
You know, Steph, you have
your YouTube channel.
But on the opposite
end, there's also
kind of the increase
in cyberbullying.
And I was wondering if
you had any experiences
with that or friends
growing up with that
and how people now can kind
of address that and work
through it?
STEPHANIE FROSCH: I
mean, cyberbullying
is definitely-- it's a
huge issue that's going on.
And I feel like as
technology is increasing
and we're being connected
in so many different ways,
there's also many
different ways we
can come up with precautions.
I mean, before
you get on a bike,
you know, there's the
chance of falling.
And that could happen
with going online as well.
So even what I've
noticed is there's ways
that you can even block phrases
from showing up on comments.
So I could flag any LGBTQ+ slur
or word that I just don't want
to see on there, and they
will be completely gone.
And then you're not
giving those people
their voices, because I
feel like the reason why
cyberbullying continues is
because you allow them to have
the power by even-- even when
I get people commenting back
saying, you can't say this.
This is awful.
That's what they
want, a reaction.
So by simply taking
their voice away,
that's the easiest way to win.
And it doesn't
need to affect you.
MARS HALLMAN: I don't have
a huge online presence.
I just don't.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I
think it also applies to,
like, people without online
presences because, you know,
even within they're kind of like
sphere of people they interact
with, you have
Facebook accounts,
and there's a lot of people that
you're kind of, like, friends
with and then they're kind
of more acquaintances.
And, like, growing up you're
on these accounts a lot.
And kind of the responses
on those personal accounts
are almost more personal
attacks and can be, like, harder
to work through.
And so do you have any
comments regarding that?
MARS HALLMAN: Back in middle
school, I was Facebook savvy.
Tail end of My Space
and then Facebook.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Wow.
I wasn't allowed one.
You are so much
cooler than I was.
MARS HALLMAN: What?
MRS. HALLMAN: I
had the password.
MARS HALLMAN: Oh.
That's my mom who
had my password.
And until I went through
and was like, why
am I friends with these
people, occasionally there
was the f-slur, the q-slur,
the d-slur, the t-slur,
all those fun ones.
And I would, in shame,
delete the messages.
But it would still,
like, be there.
Like, someone said that to me.
Someone who sees me daily.
So what I would suggest
doing, block the person online
and block them IRL.
Control your circles.
Control your safe spaces.
Try not to let those toxic
people into where they can even
touch you.
AUDIENCE: Good advice.
Thank you.
MARS HALLMAN: Thank you.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for being here.
So I have a question.
So it seems to me
that you're actually
kind of advocating on two
fronts, unfortunately.
The front of being LGBTQ+,
and any other letters,
and the front of people
that people tend to be mean
to and what that's like.
And that's very sad, but it
feels like it's very true.
So how do you kind of find
the balance between that
and, like, keep both
of these messages
kind of separate and important?
MARS HALLMAN: I try to make sure
any safe space that I'm part of
or create is a safe
space for all people.
But it's important
when you're organizing
those kind of spaces,
you have your message
clear from the beginning.
And make sure everyone
involved knows
this is a space
for trans rights.
This is a space for
intersectional feminism.
This is a place for this group.
But also make sure
any safe place
is a safe space universally.
So as the organizer,
as you, know,
the moderator, the
organizer, the facilitator,
it's kind of up to that
person to make sure
that everything stays
separate and important.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: What I've
experienced, especially
at my school, was
when I was bullied
for being gay, I feel like it
wasn't that I was being bullied
for being gay, it was just I
was being bullied because it
was something different.
So before I was
out, I was made fun
of because I had a
wheelie backpack.
And I had a friend who was made
fun of because she hasn't cut
her hair since she was four.
And I'm like, whether
I came out as gay
or I came out as,
you know, a bear,
I would be made fun of
because it was different.
And especially having a
safe space to go to, which
I didn't have at the time.
I know if I did have a GSA, my
entire adolescent experience
would be completely
different, but online I
did have those safe spaces and
I did have those resources.
And I feel like
it is so important
to continue to grow
these safe spaces
and to show the entire world no
matter-- because you can come
out when you're five,
you can come out
when you're 50,
that no matter what,
there is a community for you.
Even if you feel like
you won't fit in even,
even if you feel like no
one's going to understand,
there's going to be people who,
even if they don't understand,
they will listen and
they will be there.
And that is the most
important thing,
because you want to
surround yourself
with people who
listen, not people
who throw you down and
don't let you be heard.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you
so much for being here.
Thank you for being excellent
advocates and activists
and just beacons of positivity.
So let's give them
a round of applause.
STEPHANIE FROSCH: Thank
you for having us.